[Music]
the 2019 Met Gala was 1,000% glitz
glamour and fashion but it's what
happened after the stars worked it for
the cameras that has everyone talking
now we're counting down 7 things you
didn't see on the pink carpet
starting with Haley Bieber being hashtag
wife goals dancing to Justin Bieber's
song
yeah that was kendall Jenner rubbing
Hayley stomach but as far as we know
there's no baby news to report yet
moving on from maybe babies to baby
boomers share made a surprise
performance the 72 year old icon brought
the house down with a mini concert
featuring Abbas 1974 hit song Waterloo
and several of her classics including if
I could turn back time and believe if
the met couldn't be any more fabulous
sure let's sort of share it in the mix
so this event is actually closed to the
public but good news for all of us non
famous civilians tons of the stars
inside the event like Gwen Stefani
Tracee Ellis Ross and Hailee Steinfeld
actually broke the know social media
rule and instagrammed the moment check
it out
[Music]
even the American Horror Story cast got
down together next up well I'll just let
this picture do the talking no your eyes
aren't deceiving you that's the famously
reclusive rumored couple Katie Holmes
and Jamie Foxx these two have never
officially confirmed rumors and reports
that they're dating and they did not
walk the carpet together but guys I'm
just gonna say it nothing says we are an
official fierce AF couple like matching
formal wear check it out his shoes
matched her purple dress that was
planned it had to be right oh but the
cuteness didn't end there next on our
list is this sweet moment between
kendall Jenner yes she made our list
twice and Harry Styles the pic was taken
inside the event and it has everyone
talking because these two have sparked
dating rumors on and off since 2013 when
they were spotted driving away together
after dinner then again in 2015 they
were snapped getting cozy on a yacht and
then last June she was actually seen
cheering him on at the final show of his
Harry Styles live on tour world trek in
LA I am here for it if these to ever go
the distance I will happily cosign on
that relationship just look at how good
they look together I mean their babies
would be so cute but that's not the only
epic reunion to go down at the Met Gala
cameras snapped
Game of Thrones stars richard madden and
sophie turner inside the Metropolitan
Museum of Art looking happy as hell to
see each other
Richard previously starred on Game of
Thrones as Robb Stark the older brother
to Sophie's character but eventually he
left the show after a not-so-fun wedding
oh and if you're wondering who that
looker-on is it's Sophie's new hubby Joe
Jonas all the feels so cute number two
on our list Kim Kardashian's after-party
look Kim rocked not one but two looks to
the Met Gala he or she is in the bright
blue latex mini dress matching gloves
mid
calf boots and a silver and blue tinsel
fringe wig
can we just say hashtag extra and I like
it and last but not least on our list
drumroll please
Katy Perry's hamburger ensemble oh yeah
you heard me
hamburger ensemble Katy Perry turned
heads on the stairs in this chandelier
costume then she outdid herself changing
into this look and if you thought it
couldn't get better oh you are so wrong
her stylist documented her changing into
the look in the bathroom and look who
walks by hey J love
okay that's worthy of a replay hey J
love okay J Lo is all of us she is
confused as hell and so are we
here's something I have to point out she
is actually wearing a lettuce dress
under her costume I mean no one even saw
that except for maybe Orlando Bloom dear
Anna Wintour I think my invitation to
the Met was lost in the mail it's okay I
forgive you see you next year
sincerely Hallie of course et will be
here to bring you all the big fashion
moments all year long so be sure to keep
it locked on et until next time I'm
Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]